oh boy oh boy boy boy
[Music]
come on bring it on Oh God he's velh
down oh this is okay hey whoa hey hi
what do I do I don't know what to do Oh
God
you better not come any closer oh I
really give it to you though just warm
up I just won you intimidate kodachi
eventually oh oh oh geez oh I gotta keep
up the speed keep up the speed keep up
the speed whoo whoo oh my fingers grab
it okay
all right then just another go ah lose
the hair fur you ain't gonna get past my
defense I've improved the strength of my
blacks and you ain't never I know how to
beat you Oh pelvic thrusts oh yeah but
slam combo Wow god damn it that was hard
that was legitimately hard ow my hands
you better not come any closer
oh no really give it to you
odd but you know what I'm Sam a window